c'était le temps des généraux quand les
dinosaures comme moi régner sur la peur
mais ça c'est pas moi c'est moi
ces bons à rien cassé je t'ai font cela
s'est fait ouais c'est longuet d'abord
je défonce calmes et après je me cap de
sept heures papa tu es sûr qu'on est de
la même portée
le père était quelqu'un que tout le
monde admire et le protecteur du
troupeau moi j'étais le petit corps
j'étais pas prêt maintenant c'est bon
comment aurais-je pu savoir que le monde
que je connaissais allait bientôt
changer
non
un jour
ce fut mon tour
de protéger ma famille
et d'embarquer le troupeau
dans la plus grande aventure
tous les temps
là
noël
vous allez vivre une aventure
si réel
que vous aurez l'impression d'y être sur
la terre des dinosaures
le film en 3d